what we have here is a simulation
created by Peter Cole encouraged in
response to one of our computer science
challenge just so how many particles
might interact gravitationally and the
whole point of the simulation is to get
an intuition for how galaxies form why
they have the structures they have why
solar how solar systems form how they
have the structures they have and and
how gravity alone can kind of define
that structure and what's really
interesting about the simulation besides
the fact that it's just mesmerizing and
extremely cool it shows the particles
collide once they get to a certain
critical mass you see that they get
colored yellow maybe to indicate that
they are now a star fusion can now occur
and you can zoom in at different levels
to really see how the different
particles or the different masses are
interacting and then you can actually
rotate you can actually rotate that to
see a little bit clearer this is if I'm
looking kind of right on top of it to
see how they're interacting and it's a
three-dimensional simulation so it's a
very rich it's a very rich way of
thinking about these and what's exciting
for me is the it's highly dependent on
what the initial conditions are in an
earlier version of Peters simulation he
did not give a net angular momentum to
the system and so you did not have as
much of kind of the planet satellite or
as much of the disk structures forming
although right here we don't have too
much of a disk structure although it
does seem to kind of there's there does
seem to be a dominant plane in this
scenario and what's exciting is here we
have a binary system sometimes you you
restart it you might not have a binary
system depending on the initial
conditions you might have something that
starts to look like the Milky Way
sometimes you might have something that
looks very different than the Milky Way
and it really gives us clues of why we
see such diversity especially in when
we're looking at galaxies the structures
of galaxies that is highly dependent on
initial conditions one can argue that
our own solar system did have some net
initial angular momentum because the
current theory is it was it what really
catalyzed it was a nearby supernova that
sent a shockwave and allowed the dust
that would form our solar system to
reach a critical mass and start to
condense into the Sun and the planets
and so this isn't at least in my mind
too unrealistic of a scenario and it's
really cool to look at and it really
gives you a sense of thing you
see you have a binary star they're kind
of orbiting around each other or reading
around the center of mass which kind of
looks like around each other and then
this star right over here has its own
kind of captive planet that is just
rotating around it we can see a little
bit clearer if we had a very at least
from this perspective a very close range
we can zoom in a little bit more to see
it a little bit better this has a
satellite but then they're also kind of
dancing around each other so it's a
really fascinating a really fascinating
simulation I could really stare at this
and play with it for days and I
encourage you to play with it
restart it see how the initial
conditions or what type of solar systems
or galaxies you might end up with
whether they form disks whether you have
binary systems or not whether you have
planets with satellites and then if you
are more advanced actually play with the
code and see if you can really change
the initial conditions the starting
velocities of things the number of
particles and things the distribution of
mass that you start off with the angular
momentum that you start off with and see
how that might change the structure of
the universe's that you create and I'm
going to add an annotation to this video
that links directly to this simulation
and I'll also put the link inside of the
description so have fun I could
literally spend hours with this it's a
fascinating fascinating module that he's
created resume in and out and I really
thank Peter : Grich for this incredible
contribution